مع كل عام تتكرر معاناه النازحين في
مخيمات الشمال السوري بشكل كبير مع قدوم
الشتاء ومع بدايه الامطار ليله امس كان
هناك هطول الامطار تسببت باضرار في
المخيمات كما نشاه حال المخيمات والمشاهد
الخيام المهتدئه حقيقه بالاضافه الى ان
المياه التي تجمعت بالقرب منها وبين
الخيام تسببت بصعوبه في التنقل بين الخيام
معنا هنا احد النازحين من المخيمات تحكي
لنا كيف كانت ليله
واحنا بخير وتفوت علينا الميه يلا ننزل
بالحرامات وميه ممتلئات وكل الناس قاعدين
لا طبعا
المطر هيك علينا
وما عدنا خذنا يعني ما عندنا اعلان نفرح
حالنا في وضعنا الميه محمد فوت علينا وعلى
الصبح وعلى الوجه صباح طول ما توصل تفوت
علينا عم نشطف ونطلع
نحول الولد العالمي
ايضا هنا بشكل واضح التجمع المياه الذي
يكون في مخيمات هذه المخيمات التي هي في
الشمال السوري تتخطى اكثر من 1600 مخيم
جميعهم مقام خارج المدن وفي اراضي زراعيه
غير مجهزه بالخدمات لا يوجد فيها صرف صحي
او شبكه مياه او حتى كهرباء همم معاناه
الاكثر من مليونين نازح في هذه المخيمات
تتكرر مع كل عام ان كان في فصل الصيف او
في فصل الشتاء محمد الجزائري الجزيره ريف
حلب